here in nevada we are a little over a
week away from the primary elections and
this weekend locals all across las vegas
are taking advantage of early voting
madison kimbrough joins us live at a
voting site in centennial hills near
tropical parkway and centennial center
with more on what you need to know to
cast your vote madison
yeah sasha if you want to make your vote
count now is the time as you can see we
are here at the centennial hills
location as there's only one week left
before the big day on june 14th this
location off centennial center center
boulevard opened today at 9 00 a.m and
will be open until friday june 10. the
turnout today has been steady with
people not letting the heat getting them
down from coming out and casting their
vote other long-term sites include
desert breeze park and the boulevard
mall north las vegas residents able to
submit their ballots for city mayor city
council awards one and three and
municipal court judge departments one
and two here's what some locals at the
area had to say about coming out today
and why it was important for them to do
so
i'm actually i work for
headquarters metro headquarters so i
figured i wanted to come down
and
help support our community and voting is
a very big deal especially in
our day name
if you are a henderson resident early
voting started may 31 at henderson city
hall access will be available through
thursday june 9. that's from 7 30 a.m to
5 30 p.m this location is now closed for
the day but at last count the site had
270 voters today and for a full list of
candidates and voting sites you can go
to our website at 8newsnow.com for all
that information reporting live in
centennial hills madison kimbrough live
local now